All right, cool.
I've got a shopping list name that
anyone in the world can update.
Let's call on some users and
see what the big picture looks like.
Okay, we have three of us using
the version of the app that you
just created.
When the app starts up,
it attaches a value event listener.
This listener gets triggered
immediately, it takes a snapshot, and
it delivers the snapshot of
Dummy Data to us immediately.
So all of our apps read Dummy Data.
Okay.
Let's say my roommate Kagure changes
the name of the shopping list to
Kagure's List.
What happens with Firebase?
It occurs in milliseconds but
it's fairly complex.
Okay, go for it, Kagure.
Once she does this, the app sends the
data to a specific location in Firebase.
Base URL plus listName.
And the value in Firebase
changes to Kagure's List.
Because listName changed, the listeners
triggered, and a snapshot is taken.
Because we were all sitting
at the same location and
it changed, we all get the updated data
in the form of a database snapshot.
Then the onDataChanged has triggered all
of our apps with this data snapshot.
And if you wrote your code correctly,
then everyone's UI display changes
to seamlessly show the updated data.
And the same thing happens no
matter who changes the data.
One person will change it,
and it updates for everyone.
And that's what's so cool about
reading and writing data in Firebase.